eine brandneue service station für
radfahrer steht im rheinland pfälzischen
nassau an den sogenannten rat städten
können sich radler informationen
besorgen
ihr gepäck lagern oder die elektroräder
aufladen das problem für den bau dieser
anlage habe die kommune gar keine
baugenehmigung hier steht ein schwarzbau
der stadt welzow gepennt nachdem was ich
alles gelesen habe ist das der reinste
schildbürgerstreich ist das ding schwarz
gebaut wurden und dass seine behörde ist
schon irgendwie lustig finde ich klasse
die radstädter gehört zum radweg
deutsche einheit der von bonn nach
berlin führt die station in masse aus
die aufwendigste variante und hat satte
266.000 euro gekostet aber mit der wahl
des bauplatzes liegt die kommune völlig
daneben denn hinter der station steht
ein denkmalgeschütztes haus
die vier meter hohe metallkonstruktion
davor verstand dem klick auf das
historische gebäude für diesen standort
hätte die stadt niemals eine
baugenehmigung bekommen
trotzdem wird das ding da hingestellt
seit ende 2018 ist es fertig aber noch
immer außer betrieb es schade dass man
da nicht vor drüber nachgedacht hat ob
man das darf soll oder wo sie hin könnte
und das sei jetzt steuergelder
verschwendet wurden ich brauche in
deutschland für alle möglichen dinge
halt genehmigungen und bei so einer
radstation finden die zeit wenn es
gerade für die öffentlichkeit ist finde
ich schon ziemlich prekäre angelegenheit
an dem ganzen verfahren waren die stadt
nassau die verbandsgemeinde bad ems
nassau unter rhein lahn kreis beteiligt
die schuld für das desaster will keiner
übernehmen und vor die kamera möchte
auch niemand schriftlich teilt uns der
verbandsbürgermeister mit dass von den
denkmalpflege behörden für den
mittlerweile erfolgten bau der
radstädter keine baugenehmigung in
aussicht gestellt werden kann
mit anderen worten das teure stück muss
wieder weg
die ganzen also egal wer geht kopf
werden vorbei sagt kann ja nicht sein
wenn der einfache bürger nun nun wie
seine garage
ein carport erweitern glauben möchte da
kommt auflagen auflage ordnung hier wird
vor dem gesetz die nasa und machen sich
die behörden jetzt wieder auf die suche
nach einem neuen standort für die
radstädter dieses mal werden sie
hoffentlich die deutschen baugesetze
ganz fest im auge behalten